bien troussé squeeze aujourd'hui on se
trouve une nouvelle fois à tokyo on va
retourner au parc ueno
et oh merci merci vraiment me en recul
est j'étais en train de vous dire qu'on
allait aujourd'hui aller au zoo de
winehouse avait là des enfants n'étaient
au parc est bien là on va au zoo voilà
et je vais le redire 18 fois mais on
arrête elle a tout de suite devant
peut-être des tigres je viens d'arriver
regarder il y à un milliard de personnes
de plus que la dernière fois c'est
incroyable en fait c'est le premier jour
due à un ami donc tous les gens viennent
ici pour voir des cerisiers en fleurs
voilà lots avoir des animaux et des
hipsters tout comme tout le monde
regardez tous ces petits cerisiers en
fleurs c'est extrêmement jolie je viens
d'entrer à l'aide de mon ticket dans cet
endroit un peu les eaux on va tout de
suite voir ce qui nous intéresse les
pandas on va voir un couple et histoire
triste ils ont fait un petit et ce petit
est décédé en 2012 donc ça a été un gros
coup dur pour le japon de zschopau sont
là et faire plein de câlins ces pandas
pour leur remonter le moral
ou alors jahnke de malades mais on peut
déjà apercevoir d'ici et un soigneur qui
va lui ramener du bambou l'aps qu'il a
déjà tout bouffer le panda la vue je
pense qu'il va jeter sur les pouces il
se lève j'ai jamais vu un animal aussi
une cause et que ça les mains paresseux
c'est moins posée ce pays d'othe
attention à la base cet animal est
carnivore il est tellement flemmards
qu'il a arrêté de chasse et pourra en
bouffer des plantes
je viens de trouver le meilleur animal
du zoo le pigeon asiatique est
totalement faux c'est en fait un faisan
cet oiseau fait ma taille a pas de
problème enfin je crois que le tigre au
road parce que juste à côté à l'enclos
de teindre un truc comme ça et on se
doute qu'il aurait de lâcher un petit
creux vient de trouver un bébé panda
c'est super rare y en a qu'un qui se
baladent dans tout le lot est juste là
attention petit défi y trouvait l'animal
sur ce court extrait de vidéo
il adore montrer leur petit tu d'animal
ici on a deux otaries en pleine séance
de bronzage fait huit années qu'elles
n'ont pas bougé est-ce qu'elles n'ont
pas l'air heureux sans déconner on se
rapproche de l'animal que je voulais le
plus voir le panda roux
même si on voit que dalle à cause du
reflet regardez comme ils sont mignons
c'est vraiment l' inverse d pendant
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure c'est à dire
qu ils sont hyper vif il bouge partout
ils se battent les couilles du bambou
depuis ce qu'ils mangent des fruits et
aussi avec dockers d'avoir c'est le
symbole de mozilla firefox allait revoir
je viens de voir deux chiens sauvages
il faut se dire que django s'il avait
été à l'état sauvage il aurait peut-être
ressemble à ça on a du mal à y croire
les chauves souris je sais pas du tout
ce que c'est
il a disparu et la médaille de l'animal
le plus mignon du zoo est remis à un
on se quitte sur un canard japonais en
fait l'espèce japonais s'est même que
nous met tous en quatre fois plus grande
ces fonds ce n'est pas un canard mais
emballé inseps rex dyslexiques donc ce
truc descendants des dinosaures
ce qu'on peut dire qu'ils sont quand
même tombés bien bas on fait tout un la
gamme avec les crocodiles et les arts
tout ça mais non c'est un vrai la poule
qui descendit dinosaures spain blague je
suis actuellement dans l'endroit où il
ya le plus de street food de tout le
japon plein de ce temps là les gens qui
vendent de la nourriture
après la pomme d'amour découverte la
fraise d'amour c'est bien ce que vous
penser la même chose mais que dans les
phrases les gens je suis au paradis
puisque je viens de trouver le assassiné
c'est ok elle a refait le assassination
classeront café corsen c'est partout
dans ton assiette
il est absolument partout on n'a jamais
vu au tour d' affiches réunis au mètre
carré
il ya toutes sortes de moody's un ballon
dégonflé par exemple les petits cookies
des stylos des tubes phocéen parce que
c'est les trousses tu peux aussi acheter
les couilles de colomb un objet
magnifique le sommes actuellement à la
sky tree tower et projets des ouvriers
sur les vitres et un petit spectacle de
projections sur des vitres c'était pas
mal du tout je redescends c'est
également à profiter de la vue sur l'est
terrorisés j'ai trouvé la technique
efficace un sol en verre à 300 mètres de
haut je vais pas vous mentir j'ai un
bout en bout le vertige et c'est parfait
ce qu'il nous fallait pour bien terminer
cette petite fille journée konichiwa
c'est effectivement un nouveau jour et
le dernier jour au japon après on rentre
en france et on fait des vidéos pour les
abonnés souhaitent beaucoup de gens n'y
avait que j'en fais ici même au japon
aujourd'hui nous allons à assat koussa
un quartier traditionnel
on va peut-être se faire un petit temple
il ya le temple sensoji là-bas à l'eau
se retrouve la bastille part j'ai trouvé
un bonnet [ __ ] superbe un gp qu'il est
on va le remettre à l'eau mais pas
déconner moi je pense qu'il ya quelqu'un
là haut qui a envoyé ce bonnet pour
cacher cette coupe de cheveux roses
petit café je viens d'arriver on peut
voir déjà ici les choses traditionnelles
le temple est au bout de cette allée que
voyaient et ça c'est la porte entre s'y
déchirent où on n'a pas le goût je vais
acheter la nourriture ici et ce qu'ils
ont donc le stand c'est un lapin ce que
tu manges ressemblent à des petites
crottes de l'apa et en ski et de
sucettes en fait de la poudre darricau
blanc c'est délicieux et il est là par
peser kaka s'ajoutera un élevage de la
bataille et nous sommes devant le temple
est grand que le petit top qu'on a fait
la dernière fois c'est de la fumée sacré
voilà il faut s'en remettre sur le
visage pour devenir sacré né ici il ya
aussi ça devant tous les temples c'est
une petite fontaine avec de l'eau bénite
et il faut s'en remettre sur les mains
la boire elle a recraché pour être
encore plus bénis
ces jumelles il ya des petites peintures
au plafond très cool et ici c'est un
dragon qui tient de faire dans sa main
de cette perle réalise tout et veut et
peut guérir les maladies voilà on fait
le lien riverains veulent ball z et le
dragon avec les boules à j'adore
l'humour
quel acteur sommes actuellement dans un
jardin traditionnel japonais
c'est extrêmement beau il ya toujours de
petits lacs avec des carpes obèses qui
doivent être très bien nourris malades
jouera je suis homo karpine offre n 6
bat sco n'a pas envie de vivre ici c'est
une maison de thé en fait
regardez il ya une grand-mère qui nous a
fait du thé il est bon c'est du vrai
tekki tarage bien alors les grands-mères
ici au japon tu vas vraiment envie de
tout les prendre dans tes bras et de les
couvrir de cadeaux et de câlins c'est
comme les grands mères françaises encore
plus gentil je viens de commander du sap
est une juste parce que dans son
restaurant là le sac est servi dans du
bambou
je m'excuse auprès de ma mère
heureusement qu'au moins il n'est pas du
tout remplir avant auquel cas je serai
bc d'échec le sac et en france chaque
fois que j'en ai pris dans ma vie c'est
très très amer aux à-coups dans une
petite rente mi am sexuelles dans ce que
je viens de dire
à la vôtre basse-navarre et le sac est
franchie très parfumée donc être
maintenant dans la tokyo one piece
towers c'est parti c'est ce baptiste le
fait c'est baptiste nouveau paix non ça
c'est quand tu veux dire sébastien mais
que totalement du sexy cantonaux
s'embrouille avec sa fille d'avoir envie
d'être au milieu c'est à ce moment là
que les mecs qui ne regardent pas one
piece ne comprennent rien ce que je dis
je suis désolé ça par contre c'est
universel et les comprendre
des [ __ ] de pervers pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas one piece plus up est un
personnage qui est un lance-pierre est
actuellement va lancer des pierres
c'est ce parti au com à tous les jeux
j'étais nul à chier doit-on le stand de
l'oma devoir couper des moules et de
cadeaux à pleine vitesse
c'est le taux le moins crédible la fin
et r je fais les valises pour mon à
l'est de ce pays avec une fatigue
extrême
les valises sont de fait elles sont sous
m marino décollage
c'est la tête d'un mec qui vient de
rentrer d'un voyage de trois semaines de
retour à la maison j'ai extrêmement
fatigué mais j'ai dormi comme un bébé
dans l'avion parlant ça n'a pas suffi
que j'arrive même pas dû être si simple
je vais maintenant monter ce blog ou
j'attendrai de dormir 30 heures avant je
suis content de turgot alors oui pour le
coup ça fait très très plaisir et je
vous dis à trouver dans une prochaine
vidéo
les blocs japon sont terminés personne
n'a plus pour tout bientôt courbis